alors on vient de parler avec siri de
putman de la dépendance à l'héroïne
mais là le héros il est vraiment
dépendant lui aussi c'est un film soit
dépendance leur donner tout compris
c'est un film sur la dépendance le héros
son vice
c'est claude françois y en a qui tombe
dans l'alcool un exemple dans la drogue
comme dans le sexe d'autres tombent dans
le jeu lui tombe dans claude françois la
religion claude françois la religion
cloclo ouais c'est ça si l'on est il est
adepte de cette religion voilà une comme
ça
ouais c'est exactement ça or en change
pas de sujet en fait non ce que c'est
être un petit peu moins dangereux une
conceptual continuity voilà oui alors
d'abord vous avez eu l'idée d'un film
vous allez voir poelvoorde ils ont voulu
faire un film là-dessus vous a dit oui
au fait t'es gentil est un roman est
revenu voir sa durée 5 ans vous avez été
d'un courage exemplaire
je me suis arrangée pour que poelvoorde
joue dans mon livre on va dire que j'ai
injecté j'ai pu leur disais mon roman
avec sa verve sa scansion en stage j'ai
foutu du pouvoir dans le bouquin et un
jour je lui dis tiens lis ça et émettant
mais c'est moi ça ouais et donc du coup
il avait envie de faire le film mais
s'ils avaient dit non vous n'auriez pas
fait le final on serait rentré chez moi
continuer à écrire des livres vraiment
faire de toute façon
anissa corto c'était pas mal non plus
souvent me dit est ce que c'est comment
de faire un film et je réponds je ne
sais pas faire un film moi je ne sais
faire que un film avec benoît poelvoorde
ouais j'en fais un meilleur à julie
depardieu dans un pool de vos rêves et
obsessionnelle et alors vous avez dit
aussi personne d'autre ne peut le
réaliser à ma place c'est quand même
gonflé parce qu'elle vous enfilez plein
de thunes pour faire ce film alors vous
aviez jamais fait de film avoir dit
qu'il voulait me fille est encore plus
et une pour ne pas le faire donc non je
voulais pas céder parce que on n'est
jamais mieux trahi par soi même veine
travers moi même car je ne suis pas très
fiable y compris envers moi même c'est
difficile le cadre l'image comme ça
c'est des choses et je faisais de la bd
avant d'écrire des bouquins ça m'a
vachement aider en fait ouais et puis
après j'ai regardé plein de films
maintenant pour un premier film on peut
dire c'est je parle visuellement assez
réussie quand même parce que c'est 50
boulot j'ai commencé ce truc que j'avais
29 ans j'aurai bientôt 36
c'est dur alors quant à julie depardieu
vous êtes rencontrés dans un bar en 1996
tous les deux et vous a dit je suis sûr
qu on travaillera ensemble
alors moi j'ai rigolé je ne savais pas
qu'elle était fille depardieu et une
blonde que je draguais aller non en fait
moi j'étais avec une copine qui était
brune qui a l'air de plaire aussi de
regarder la télé donc la vie et non on
était toutes les deux et me dit j'ai un
court métrage là avec un de terre un
truc très hystérique j'ai bien compris
j'avais dit ware écoutez moi je ne suis
pas triste donc ça tombe bien donc il
drague en disant qu'ils étaient des
cours ouais c'est bien l'inter tenait un
stand qui imprime à 50 orale oui et deux
ans plus tard vous l'avez fait ouais
mais il a de la suite dans les idées ce
garçon là parce que ça fait deux fois de
suite
alors vous avez dit vous en tous les cas
dans tous les films que je ferais julie
oui c'est la meilleure actrice de sa
génération assez devenir actrice les
générations oui il est incroyable parce
que quand on arrive sur un tournage la
chose la moins importante pour elle de
la journée ces moments où on tourne
ouais ouais nan mais apparemment
apparemment apparemment mais sa façon de
se concentrer c'est d'en avoir rien à
[ __ ] elle se fout d'être là bas quand
on regarde le truc public
quand on est quand on regarde sur le
plateau d'une qu'est-ce que c'est que ce
truc mais ça va jamais marché et quand
on voit les rushs ça marche on voit pas
pourquoi c'est étonnant vous dit julie
moi j'ai pas de propositions à faire sur
un plateau alors que tous les acteurs en
font des propositions au real j'ai pas
d'imagination j'ai pas d'idée et j'ai
pas tiens à ce que c'est on ne vous me
demande qu'est ce que je peux et quand
on me dit non ça va pas alors
effectivement je commence à me
non lui un peu là haut mais n'en suis
pas quelqu'un qui propose beaucoup je
propose moi c'est je trouve que c'est
déjà c'est déjà ça mais je sais vous
avez ce côté là c'est quand vous étiez
petit à l'école m'a raconté ça une fois
quand elle avait une copine protestante
était protestante une copine juive a été
suivi à lille
ouais zelig un peu oui vous dites j'ai
aucune admiration pour les gens qui
réussissent
je trouve au contraire beaucoup plus
émouvant ce qu'ils ratent j'aime bien
les gens qui réussissent
ça ne me fait rien la réussite est la
forme la plus subtile de l'échec
ouais voilà j'aime regarder les filles à
noter c'est pour ça qu'ils sont encore
pas si tu veux oui la visite très jolie
je me fous de plaire l'enjeu c'est pas
trop me détester c'est pas plaire au
plus grand nombre
ouais ouais c'est plaire à une petite
poignée à qui on a envie de plaire ouais
alors voulais pas spécialement être une
star voulait devant mon ambition ça va
très bien là mon ambition c'est d'avoir
des poules
oui mon projet 2404 le poulailler
j'en aurai 3 je sais déjà les prénoms
vous énoncez mon projet voilà c'est un
truc pas d'enfant voulait pas d'enfant
ouais enfin peut-être peut-être non pas
du tout vous dites que vous trouver
ridicule et les les actrices qui disent
dans paris match ou dans gala depuis que
j'ai un enfant je vis un rêve mais
j'essaierai franchement si ça m'arrive
je suis fait un pari donc c'est un pari
idiot si vraiment si je le dis
je me fais dire un gros nuage je ne veux
pas le dire ça parce que c'est une
évidence on le sait à quoi bon le dire
et je trouve ça ridicule de moi en tout
cas je ne dirais pas même si c'est vrai
cependant par les matchs en tout cas
voilà non je ne dirais pas non
même si même si c'est vrai mais ça
m'arrache la caisse dédiée aux jeunes
alors contrairement à votre père et
votre frère vous dit vraiment vous
défier très très peu la chronique
vous êtes d'une calme études absolument
exemplaire non mais c'est surtout que
non j'ai rien à dire enfin pas au plus
grand nombre
on va essayer quand même l'affairé
intervient quand on s'appelle depardieu
quand on s'appelle depardieu est ce qu
on fait des pâtes chaque fois qu'on ne
tombe de vélo
non moi si je faisais une pub je serais
pour les ménages est-ce que les seuls
trucs enquête je croise les produits
ménagers je pense à eux quand on
s'appelle depardieu est ce qu'on tient
bien l'alcool
ouais ouais cette famille ouais c'est ce
qu'ont fait son vin soi même est ce que
quand on s'appelle depardieu on investit
son argent un peu n'importe comment non
quand on en a pas est-ce qu'on a plus
facilement des tableaux restaurant non
parce qu'on dit pas son nom
on a plus facilement des restaurants
est-ce qu'on a forcément un drôle de
rire quand on s'appelle depardieu nom
revient les lumières très près est ce
que quand on s'appelle de pardies on a
parfois envie de porter un autre nom oui
oui mais là c'est un peu tard maintenant
j'aurais dû j'aurais dû le faire à 12
ans comme on m'avait proposé un qui
avait proposé ce pas mon père je voulais
que tu t'appelles comment je sais pas il
avait pas proposé mais il avait dira je
vois que ça te les dunes de par ds non